[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech
this is the tony michaels podcast and
this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
happy hump day
isn't it fun
to have an actual president of the
united states
who isn't a petulant [ __ ] child
who can actually stand up and speak to
the american people without dividing the
american people and
that's something ain't it boy
boy it's a long time coming isn't it
i i even tweeted
the better america is joe biden
it's the truth
it's the truth
rather joe biden is the best of us
we are the best of joe biden for sure
what i mean by that is that last night
joe biden said the word americans made
in america
he talked about buying american products
building american products
just like trump did
the the the difference
the difference is joe biden's actually
trying to actually do something about it
uh the democrats are actually trying to
deliver those things that the trump
supporters yelled and screamed and
chanted
speaking of screaming and chanting
[Laughter]
we have bobo the clown
and marjory hoof foot green chanting
chanting at joe biden last night i i
don't know if they thought like oh he's
the president and this is a rally so
we're supposed to chant i don't know
we're gonna get into it we're gonna get
into it um
[Music]
we're definitely going to talk about the
outburst
from lauren bobo the clown bobert
the show
i i messaged hey my message i tweeted
earlier rather you guys wanted me to uh
talk about
lauren bobert's little outburst
and of course i knew the [ __ ] answer
but
you know i figured i'd ask anyways i
figured i'd ask everyone's here kathy's
here debbie's here carter's here
christina hello good morning mj
david robin lisa hello hello everyone
hello everyone hello hello hello
um we're happy to have you here on the
tony michaels podcast
um you know what i think we're gonna
have um we're gonna have a rachel
bitkoffer on later on in the hour um to
talk about the state of the union
i know you guys love rachel's take so
we'll talk about that we'll talk about
what the messaging means what the
language means because you know me and
rachel like to talk about messaging a
lot like that's important because
everyone's like democrats messaging
sucks and sometimes it does
but i think we can make it better like
us as a collective group of
pro-democracy people can make that
messaging better like that's how we do
it right so we're going to have rachel
bitcoffer on here and just uh probably
at the bottom of the hour here you guys
know we do two hours every single
weekday every [ __ ] weekday i'm here
yelling into the microphone you get to
listen
noon eastern 11 central right here on
youtube twitter twitch don't forget to
subscribe
to the youtube channel
don't forget to do that
and then go like and hit the buttons and
comment down below whatever the hell you
know i don't know i'm not very good at
this youtube stuff
so do whatever it is that you're
supposed to do go to the uh the
directories too we've been having a lot
of new new listeners on all the
directories even the banned ones are not
the bad ones the boycotted ones the
boycotted ones boy the boycotted ones
there's a lot of new listeners
coming in from spotify so go go to your
favorite directory whichever one it is
right there spotify apple google uh
iheartradio wherever you listen to your
podcast and if you don't listen go pick
one out and give us a review that would
be great
great over there we have some big news
me and gabe have some big
big
big giant news coming next week
i don't know exactly when we're going to
announce this thing probably maybe maybe
tomorrow friday um but
we get the big interview coming tomorrow
as
ukraine news uh isn't as fast moving um
we want to go ahead and
and play that interview from the ottawa
data out of the gifts and go the ottawa
truckers [ __ ] thing
we want to play the uh the interview of
the data
analysis um from the data dump from
gibson go like where that money was
coming from i don't know if you guys
noticed this but the dc trucker rally
thing and i'll show you the video today
because rachel actually maybe maybe i'll
bring it on when she's when she's here
did you see the [ __ ] video of the
rally they had oh my god there was there
was there was like 10 cameras there
right of people filming it like media
right of people who wanted to see the
[ __ ] show and there wasn't a [ __ ] i mean
it was just one dude standing on this
big stage there wasn't no one watching
it was just him i mean he did a really
good job of organizing you know a pity
party but
it was fantastic so we'll we'll probably
uh we'll probably take a look at let's
take a look at the dc trucker rally
um and i'm sure it's the same [ __ ]
kind of grift that they tried to do with
gibson go with the uh the ottawa one so
we'll play that interview tomorrow
that's gonna take up the whole time
tomorrow that's why i didn't want to
play it today because i wanted to
respond to the state of the union
i felt like that was important so
tomorrow we'll play that uh that
interview it's almost two hours long so
what we'll do is we'll shoot into the
show
uh we'll introduce everything we'll do
announcements and then we'll play the
interview and then after the interview
we'll cut out of the show so tomorrow's
show will be that interview and there's
a lot of information it's it it's kind
of it's parts of it are kind of funny
because it's so obvious
and in a lot of parts of it you're like
whoa what the [ __ ] this is the actual
thing that's happening holy [ __ ] so a
lot of it will surprise you some of it
will not surprise you at all you'll be
like yep that makes a lot of [ __ ]
sense so
uh tune in tomorrow for that interview
um as we ramp up i think we we've got a
partnership on that for distribution you
guys know midas touch helped us on the
um
distribution of tasha adams and dakota
adams so go over to their page two go if
you're not liking them already go over
there they're gonna help us get the the
word out for that interview tomorrow um
so go check go check their page out be
watching their page for some of the
clips because that's uh what gabe and my
plan is is to have midas send some of
those clips so you guys can see the
clips
and then tomorrow the interview will be
during the podcast so they'll be
retweeting the the broadcast as well and
then friday we have bonehead of the week
friday this friday every single friday
really and and every single day is more
boneheads as we you know
aggregate here
you know we can't keep up with the
[ __ ] boneheads we just can't you just
you can't so today we've got um
lauren bob marger taylor green and then
kim reynolds
the iowa governor uh who gave the
rebuttal i didn't actually watch the
rebuttal yet
i i didn't i i don't i don't know if i
will maybe i'll watch clips of it we'll
probably rail rail um on her on friday
maybe today we'll we'll find time to uh
to look at some of those clips maybe
after rachel's here or maybe when
rachel's here will look at that rebuttal
we'll play some of it i'll try to find
it and we'll let rachel respond tell us
why they [ __ ] suck because
at this point
at this point and i've been saying this
for a year a whole year now they know
that we know that their ideas [ __ ]
suck
like they know that they know that we
know it right they know they got it they
got it down they know they did they
really don't even have [ __ ] ideas at
this point
i mean
the [ __ ] [ __ ] in the crowd of the
state of union last night were
regurgitating a three-word phrase
from a campaign that happened six
[ __ ] years ago
six years ago six years ago they're
regurgitating the rally cry
from six years ago after the same guy
got got to be president and had the
chance to build the [ __ ] wall
had the chance to and the wall that he
did build a stiff wind comes along and
knocks that [ __ ] to the ground
oh these people they they really they
can't even they can't even
uh lauren lauren beaubert lauren bobert
marjorie taylor greene
i seen
madison madison cawthorne oh maddie
cawthorne sitting in the front
scoffing mitch mcconnell
uh
it looked like he was on death's door
last night ted cruz looks like he had to
take a [ __ ]
you had susan collins
sitting next to tom cotton
night we did that i don't know what's
worse i don't know what's grosser susan
collins sitting next to tom cotton or
just tom cotton in general i can't
[ __ ] figure that out
you got my mind wrapped around all kinds
of [ __ ] there
at one point
the president united states joe biden
talks about medicare lowering drug cost
by making sure that drug companies
aren't gouging people and the
republicans sat there they're like no
we want prescription drugs as high as we
possibly could get them because the
american people don't deserve to have
affordable prescription drugs no matter
what even if we can do something about
it we don't care and we know that the
american people our constituents want to
make sure they pay top dollar for their
prescription drugs that they're bent
over and gouged as much as possible
that's what we want and we're not
clapping
you [ __ ] idiots
this is this is where they're at
they can't even muster up enough [ __ ]
courage to stand up and say hey yeah
that's probably a good idea that
americans aren't gouged
on prescription drug cost
probably a good idea these are the same
[ __ ] the same [ __ ]
that are so [ __ ] infuriated with the
drug companies because they came up with
a vaccine that's gonna help us in the
pandemic
they [ __ ] hate them but they love
them
they love them but they hate them but
they love them but they hate them but
they love their profits oh their profits
are so good because it comes back into
our campaigns and our pro and our
coffers
but we hate them because they tried to
end the pandemic and the pandemic was
going to be political and we want to
make sure that chaos continues which is
really funny last night
because the republicans tried this whole
chaos thing coveted chaos thing where
they're like i'm not going because i'm
not getting tested
i'm not going to take no [ __ ] covet
test so a bunch of them didn't show up
because they wouldn't take a go with
this
but they completely pointed out
that the [ __ ] boneheads that are
always yelling and screaming about covid
and and oh you're oppressing us people
like marjory taylor green and lauren
bobert to get it they had to take [ __ ]
kova test get there
so they took a cove test they only
pointed it out to us
by making theatrics about not taking a
test then
then it comes to the time of the speech
where joe biden's like yeah the cdc says
most people don't have to wear a mask
we're past masks in most places at this
point in time at this exact moment in
time
no one's wearing mask remember how oh
you're trying to control us with mind
control it's biden mind control to wear
the mask
ah
here is lauren bobert marger taylor
green
obviously tested for covid
tested negative and they're not wearing
masks
and we know they're not wearing masks
because we could hear them chanting boy
and we could especially we could
especially hear lauren bobert disparage
joe biden's son because that's what the
[ __ ] she did
that [ __ ] vile piece of [ __ ]
how anyone how anyone
could vote for that [ __ ]
i mean
put your [ __ ] pen down on the ballot
and fill in the [ __ ] circle next to
her goddamn name after knowing what she
did while joe biden was talking about
his [ __ ] son who died from cancer
you [ __ ] vile gross piece of [ __ ]
well that's just how i see it i know
that's how some of you see it
all right i think i think we should go
to the tweety tweets and attorney trends
just for a bit while we wait for rachel
to come in you guys know rachel
bitkoffer is going to join us here in a
bit i hope she joins us from her pickup
truck that's all i i always like when
she's in her in her pickup i'm not sure
i haven't um
i haven't messaged much let's see if she
got back to me here
um
no i just think we got an agreement here
she's usually on time so
let's go
let's go to the countdown
and let's do the shitless roundup until
rachel gets here
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome welcome to the
shitless roundup part of the show where
we round up all the tweety tweets in the
trendy trends of today today there's a
lot of tweety tweets and trendy trends
that are trending because of the state
of the union
um there's still a lot of news coming
out of ukraine and
russia
but um we're going to go to try to focus
on the state of the union today i know
there's
going to be some news out of ukraine
and russia as the conflict there still
continues because vladimir putin
has not been fitted for his rope yet
it's coming oh it's coming trust me it's
coming this is how tyrons work
i'm going to keep saying that because
that's the timeline of tyrants
he's not going to get around this like
he's not going to you know like retire
to fiji or some [ __ ] no that's not
what's gonna happen here and he
continues to make this worse on himself
by not just
just
throwing in the [ __ ] towel
but maybe we'll get to that let's go to
the the timeline here
um
today's bonehead of the week poll
uh this week's oh let's make this bigger
that way you see there we go okay
bonehead of the week poll we have
governor kim reynolds who gave the uh
who gave the rebuttal of the state of
the union we have representative lauren
bobert our bobo the clown as most people
know him know her uh representative
marjorie taylor green or as you know i'm
here her here
hoof foot green marjorie hoof foot green
uh kim reynolds um is 13 percent margie
taylor green coming at second
at 24.22
and lauren bobert of course
that clown
is taking the lead at 62.1 percent so go
vote you get you still got today you get
tonight tomorrow
a little bit of friday morning i believe
on this poll
so go choose who the bonehead of the
week is and then me and gabe will break
down these contestants and why they were
on the bonehead of the week
and the winner will also probably have
the alpha cuck
of the week and the dishonorable mention
i'm sure because by that time by friday
we will have more [ __ ] boneheads so
go vote in the boneheaded just go to
the at
the
excuse me at tonymichaelspod
on twitter at tonymichaelspod follow us
there that's where the bonehead of the
week poll lives okay
um
i asked this morning who wants me to
address the bobert outburst during the
state of the union today on the show you
guys had a really good response i mean
there's a lot of you guys really want me
to talk about this which we're gonna get
to it i promise um aaron parnez here
i've been i'm following aaron here
because he has family in ukraine um
so i've been following what he's been
saying seven days in ukraine still
stands
um so seven days of the invasion in
ukraine still stands i seen something
earlier that was a battle plan i believe
um i don't believe kaelin dm'd it to me
that it was uh a battle plan that
russia was hoping to take ukraine in 15
days they're about halfway there and
they're not even close to um taking
ukraine like they wanted to uh
christopher here points out something uh
very important imagine being unhappy
about big pharma not being able to bleed
americans dry by the price of gouging on
the cost of insulin uh yep there it is
see there it is oh you bastard you
bastard joe biden you son of a [ __ ]
let's go brandon let's go brandon let's
raise drug prices on americans that's
what we want
you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
we don't want lower drug is this really
what they think that americans want do
they really think that americans want
higher insulin cost
this is their [ __ ] idea of what
populism is look at kevin mccarthy here
he's going uh
i can i can smell the contribution from
the drug companies to my campaign
i can smell it
you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
this this is their populism this is this
is what people [ __ ] go go all over
the country for to stand in line with a
maga hat on and a trump shirt
to cheer on the party that's like [ __ ]
no we don't want you to have decent
decently priced insulin i mean it only
costs two dollars to make and we're
gonna charge you a thousand dollars [ __ ]
you
really this is what you think that
americans want
i've been saying this all along
democrats they they miss the mark on
this you know of course
you know i'm not excited about how joe
biden said that
medicare
needs to fix cost that's not what you
need to say you don't need to say that
you just need to say americans shouldn't
go broke because of prescription drugs
it's really [ __ ] simple
it really is now whatever bill you pass
and whatever line items are in the bill
fine whatever [ __ ]
what let let the politicians that we
elect the pro-democracy politicians that
we elect hash that out
right
but our message needs to be decent
priced drugs that's what we want we want
the party of decent price drugs and this
here this here these sad sacks of white
white nut sacks
including including you see this
[ __ ] here that ain't no [ __ ]
republican who's that sitting there
that's [ __ ] joe manchin sitting on
the republican side
and he's looking around at all the
people that are supporting the insulin
because we know we know about joe
manchin and loving insulin prices being
as high as they possibly can be [ __ ]
these [ __ ]
un-american as [ __ ] that's what that is
okay i need to go give
aaron some credit here i forgot to give
aaron credit there you go aaron thanks
for being on the shitless roundup today
and make sure i give credit ready we
give credit oh you guys seen that we had
um uh salman bhajani on our show
he won his bid in that district um in
the primary so he won the primary in
texas 92 so he will be the democrat on
the ticket
he will be the democrat on the ticket
for the general election against the
republican and as the district goes as
it's redrawn it's more of an
overwhelmingly democratic district uh
salmon is likely to take texas 92
is very cool
very cool thank you very much uh here's
here's kalyn showing that she uh took a
picture with
salman
so very cool very cool i'm glad and
hopefully we'll have him back on before
he runs against a republican i'd really
like to hear um as his race evolves what
he has to say about his race uh not just
the primary but the general
so thank you thank you for coming on the
show again
uh salmon and i hope we can talk again
okay
and if you guys want to go watch that
interview i actually posted that
interview separate um he actually talks
about how texas he thinks texas is blue
so if you don't think texas is blue or
you do or you want to know about texas
being blue even if you live in texas or
not go check out that interview because
he gives you some good insight um on not
just not just democrats in texas but
republicans in texas and how to turn a
blue it's not just about um
get getting
getting getting blue voters out it's
about registering voters because there's
a lot of people that aren't registered
in texas to vote and the more people
vote we know the more people vote
pro-democracy and i think that's
important so
go check out go check out that interview
on the youtube channel again subscribe
to the youtube channel
uh so you don't miss any of those those
great interviews that we do okay gabe
posted this this is a video and he's
trying to you know
i i believe this is what she um gabe
says did anyone else catch what lauren
bobert said during the state of the
union let's check this out let's check
out what she says here what's she
mouthed let's see
and have it counted
and look
and have it counted
and look i just tweeted nancy pelosi's
location i don't know maybe gabe is a
really good ripley lip reader here i
think he's gonna get fact-checked though
gabe i'm gonna [ __ ] dm daniel dale
if you're not careful
if you don't watch your step young man
you're putting words into bobo's
into bobo's mouth here i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go get daniel dale to fact check
this
if you're not careful you need to be
careful here
of course everyone thinks down in the
comments if you go to this tweet
everyone is trying to figure out if
that's what she really says or not i
think i think gabe may be kidding what
do you think i don't know okay uh here's
another one from gabe about last night's
little outburst look at these two
look at these two they they look excited
don't they like in this this freeze room
like you would think you would think
that this is like a trump rally right
like it's almost as if these [ __ ] get
confused
that this was this was joe biden as
president not not donald trump as
president
here they are yelling and screaming
uh build a wall what what do you mean
we're out of friend
friends of wine oh is that the box wine
yeah that's probably the box one
um
i don't know i i take i take both of
them as like
box one box wine folks what do you think
what do you think are they box wine
trash i don't know um oh here's
something from jordy this is really
funny did you guys see last night that
um after i don't know i tweeted it um
after
the state of the union
the white house had a uh twitter spaces
speaking of twitter and we're on twitter
and we like to surf twitter and the
tweety tweets and attorney trends last
night um the white house had a twitter
spaces with ron klain the chief of staff
at the white house and for joe biden and
uh midas touch occupied democrats uh
politics girl lee mcgowan
was on there they were they were
speaking um i believe it was brett that
was speaking for midas touch uh
brian taylor cohen was on there uh
speaking and asking ron questions it was
a really good space and i think they
recorded it and go watch it but jordy
here um you know everyone loves jordy
says less than two years later we did a
twitter spaces with the white house so
what he's talking about here
is uh
uh this was in apr april
6 2020. scotty here said your news
outlet has 300 followers you know
mocking midas touch um
[Laughter]
and jordy here is clowning this guy
scotty doesn't know
thanks jordy for your for your tweet
yeah you know you know a lot of people
are um
you know they want to knock liberal
outlets shows like ours shows like
politics girl oh you're you're just a
joke okay well just
hide and watch hide and watch for 2022
hide and watch uh robin says it was
great it is a great it was a great space
um it was a really great space
it wasn't really carter says there's
nothing wrong with box wine no i'm not
i'm not saying i'm not saying that that
box wine is bad i'm just saying that i
think box wine is probably what those
two drink
[Music]
oh here is the
here's the recording
um for that um post game with ron clayne
if you guys want to listen to it i will
retweet this now there's the retweet and
i'll put the uh
oh that's my tweet but i'll thank myself
why not you know pat myself on the back
think myself no but that there is the
recording so i put it at the top of the
timeline if you guys would like to go
look at it um you are more than welcome
to do that i said again it's actually
fun having it's fun having an actual
president
and that was kind of what i took from
the speech last night it's like
yeah this is kind of what presidents do
like this is what presidents do during
the state of the union
that's kind of what they do so it's very
good
uh yes it's in spaces and
oh you oh yeah i'm sorry and you said
i'm i love the sides they are
environment and you meant spaces yes the
spaces are good there are a lot of good
spaces some are kind of toxic but if you
go on them you should go in and
take a look at them and
have the
have a good time they're they're a good
time and there's more than just politics
in those spaces some talk about movies
and all kinds of [ __ ] so check out check
out the twitter spaces they're kind of
cool
and you guys should go try to speak in
them as well go give your opinion
elgin says here about kevin mccarthy
last night kevin mccarthy is texting
trump to ask if he can have his godads
back
state of the union that that is the
state of the union isn't it the state of
the union is kevin mccarthy is has to
text trump to get his gonads back thank
you eldridge scary larry said instead of
watching the state of union kevin
mccarthy is busy sexting trump did you
see that they panned to kevin mccarthy
and there he is on his [ __ ] cell
phone
there he's on his cell phone typing away
and then he kind of puts in his pocket
once oh maybe they'll maybe they'll know
maybe they'll know i'm
maybe they'll know i'm sending dirty
pictures
okay
um
justice breyer is verklempt
he's for klimt um joe biden said really
nice things about justice breyer last
night in his retirement and uh he was he
felt really heartfelt it was kind of a
really it's a really cool moment because
normally you don't see this during the
state of the union normally the the
justices try to sit stoic and show no
emotion you know they're not supposed to
justice not supposed to have emotion
just is supposed to be robot um you know
kind of thing but uh last night it was
good to see justice breyer have some
emotion
humans should have emotion that's the
thing they should do i think i think so
um hey look here rachel bitkoffer has a
few um
gifts here
historic choice
a promise kept
judge
contangy brown jackson
very good um uh if you need if you need
some gifts if you need some memes
rachel's pumping them out over there uh
here's one uh
gop ran on rural broadband they ran on
it like they want it and it's because
their constituents need it like it's a
thing that is needed for americans not
regardless of their political beliefs
regardless of it now these people need
to deliver actual good rural broadband
so they can be connected to the rest of
america the only problem is is that the
gqp doesn't want them to have it
uh democrats delivered it because
republicans love to promise and destroy
they love that i mean fascists love to
promise and destroy like that's the
thing that they do that is the thing
they do so democrats delivered real
broadband and it was great to see last
night
when joe biden brings this up
and they have to they have to figure out
are we supposed to clap for our
constituents getting broadband that we
ran on but but joe biden delivered how
do we do this what do we do oh my god i
can't i can't take it i can't take it
um so thank you rachel for your gift
speaking of rachel bitcover speaking of
rachel big governor
good morning rachel how are you
makes me happy you noticed all our uh me
and dougie's hard work
straight back team you know
yes well i i i love i love the the gifts
and the memes that you guys come up with
it it really helps get uh the
messaging in front of people um i i
think i think we live in a meme gift
society right like a social media kind
of thing those small messages are
important and last night there was those
little small hints all the way through
the state of the union where joe biden
is saying the things that republicans
want to run on right like
it it's it's so incredible to see
like just just the one instance of the
rule of broadband like you tweeted there
that that joe biden was able to say we
delivered rule broadband to you and and
he even said at one point i think he
said and you all and he looks over the
republicans and he's like and all of you
are out bragging to your constituents
about it like it was it was beautiful so
what did you think about the state of
the union what did you think about his
speech but more more realistically like
in the political body of things because
we are in a midterm cycle here what what
do you think it means for the midterm
cycle and the messaging
i mean the speech was is different right
so two weeks ago that would have been a
fully domestic speech right right now
ukraine forced it i mean really it's
hard to write that's why you had to go
bullet like so fast right he had to go
fast because they had to rewrite that
speech a couple times um to deal with
the international focus it's very rare
that a state of the union has a large
international focus the last time of
course was in iraq when bush did the
axis of evil speech that ended up
[ __ ] up the middle east for years
right right
well i mean i mean really
really it changed the whole dichotomy of
our country i mean and how we look at
war and you know and and uh occupation
really like how do we occupy forever and
ever and ever is that called war do we
call it war does americans know we're at
war i mean it really changed that a lot
yeah and you know for me like i think
like i you know i watch it as an expert
i mean number one guys what you should
understand is i don't ha i didn't have a
cop i could have gotten the speech i
could have gone and looked at it but i
didn't [ __ ] need to okay i had all
those memes ready and i knew exactly
what was coming and the party could do
this [ __ ] too imagine if there is
actually a democratic digital war room
because there's something called the dnc
war room but which which account was
running a war room last night mine are
the dnc war roommates right right
definitely mine right and i'm not saying
that to float my own [ __ ] boat what
i'm trying to say is we have to
we it's not going to be helpful just
have one woman with 126 000 followers
doing it you we all have to be running
on full cylinders and like that there if
i was in charge of [ __ ] that state of
the union night there would have been
surrogates going on the media all all
weekend to prep it all you know ukraine
would have changed a little bit but on
on tuesday certainly and then you have
to have a full-court
branding offensive on digital space you
know
and uh yeah it's it's
do you think do you think do you think
that that that kind of failed that that
they didn't get that messaging across um
that they just let it live in the speech
and not outside in more of the aggregate
and try to get the messaging in front of
people yes i mean they're not going to
do that right right well and that and
that's and that's and that's you know
kind of what's up to us right i mean
like like twitter and and people who
think that who think that quote unquote
democrats messaging sucks you're the
democrats messaging you're it like you
could you can do this so like and i'm
making it easy on them tony i mean
here's the thing is like i was so
delighted that you were showing people
the activity of last night because
eventually very soon i'm gonna load up
um the whole toolkit on to the strike
pack website but right now it's
accessible on twitter and what i'm
trying to tell people is here's the
message go and get it in front of people
right and like when i lay out the
toolkit i'll i will put a guide out with
it right
but to give you kind of a preview of
that like my vision now is like okay
let's make a digital grassroots
like basically field team right and it's
one thing to be posting [ __ ] on your
twitter or like the people you follow
but what i want to teach people to do is
take these memes these ads that are
glance ads because that's what i'm
making there and these are not memes
these are glance ads okay right right
right and they are designed to get the
message even if the person doesn't want
to [ __ ] read it
see how that works like you get you read
that message even if you don't want to
see it right right and now it's about
eyeballs right so like i can make [ __ ]
all [ __ ] dead guys at the end of the
day and you know most of like the our
miniscule budget has gone to creation
but my concern is distribution
distribution we're talking about
millions of dollars and right now i am
you know cockholded out of the money
system
of the democratic orbit because other
people are invested in ideas that i i've
argued have total merit in many
capacities but are not our best
uh source for winning in 2022 and the
texas turnout last night is a great
demonstration of that but i can promise
you the gop did not out loop them two to
one on turnout because so many voters
couldn't vote okay right because
democrats don't give a [ __ ] right now
they don't know what's happening they're
not being told to be fearful and they
don't give a [ __ ] and you can see it
right in that data right and i'll tell
you guys there's a lot of better fans
and myself included right you cannot win
that race if you do not get a massive
enthusiasm push in texas because he's
got to convert he's got to convert
right-leaning indies
and the way that you do that is not by
pretending to be a republican the way
you do that is by disqualifying the
opposition
okay
but he has to meet that with it's it's
the georgia formula you can't win in
georgia unless you can win the
conversion pool and the turnout game and
it's the same thing in texas
right so you so you think he can win but
it's it's a it's a it's uh
no not at all i would not right now guys
to be clear rachel is telling you the
truth okay
right now there's two indicators that
matter the generic ballot which when
people ask do you want republicans or
democrats to control congress in the
fall
and the enthusiasm advantage which is
how many people say they're very excited
to vote divided by party like breakdown
by party
and on both of those metrics we are
trailing
and if we continue to trail then they
will win 30 seats in the house and in 30
seats in the house are getting one
you're flipping michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin to gop hands for 2024 the
governorships and there's no way a state
lake texas can flip but that said the
texas
florida arizona and georgia races to me
are a packaged messaging opportunity
here is what your life looks like when
republicans control it
they kill you they steal your [ __ ] they
poison your children right
yeah that's so like there's a lot of
value in bedo because he's such a great
candidate and in like that narrative
being able to run through the whole sun
belt so to me this is still a very
valuable race it's not impossible to win
but we can we're not winning [ __ ] unless
we deal with a generic ballot it doesn't
matter if it's florida [ __ ] ohio with
that nut job jd vance at the end of the
day guys we have an electorate our side
our coalition is not engaged and we must
must address it
so so you're saying we have to engage
the vote and that means engaging your
neighbors engaging people you know
talking to them showing this stuff
sharing this stuff and not just not just
in dms not just on twitter but when you
go to the grocery store when you're at
your church when you're at your
community talking about these things and
and knowing how to talk about them and
how the messages is wrapped around
because really honestly the the
republican party the gqp has handed us
this on a platter this win i mean with
with their with their sycophantry to to
putin and at the the the murderous
dictator that he is and give serving
that up on a platter that that gives us
more more fodder and to show them
exactly what they want for us like oh
you want the putin for us and what does
that mean for us what does that mean for
your broadband what does that mean for
your schools what is that
that's right
right
they want to [ __ ] take your gay son
and put him in prison dude or kill him
right i mean that if you're aspiring to
putin's gay policy that's what that is
dude it's not there's no people in
russia because if you get caught being
gay your [ __ ] life is over right
right now what tucker carlson every
night is is is in uh aspiring to on fox
news right so like at the end of the day
yes you got to reach out to all of these
other people the what i call the
marginal members of the 2020-2018
coalition and the message that you give
them can't be well they got you some
bridges and [ __ ] dude it's got to be if
you don't [ __ ] vote then america as
you know it will die and these people
are coming for you
right just like putin comes for other
people yeah i mean what what is what is
to say because uh donald trump the
cheeto dust mobster stands on stage and
says putin had such a great real estate
deal what a great deal two dollars of
sanctions and he got all this land and
he took this whole country and it's a
great thing and it's fantastic
what makes you think that they wouldn't
have that view of quote unquote a blue
state right what makes you think that
they they wouldn't occupy california
what makes you think they wouldn't
overthrow a democratically elected state
government in california or new york
what makes you think they won't do that
they aspire to be putin
tons more violent dude they've got [ __ ]
tons of guns they've been cultured to
see you as an animal me as an animal and
we are not even human beings because of
right-wing media propaganda
so like dude i hate to tell you hippies
[Laughter]
well unless you see a future
in which
you know your kids can't [ __ ] eat you
probably want to vote
right and who is the people that that we
talk to because i think what you're
saying is people who don't normally
engage in politics right like me and you
are constantly me and you are constantly
involved in politics we're watching it
every single day every single move but
there are people out there that they
don't even know who the vice president
of the united states is they don't yeah
let me be clear tony we are we are one
percenters and anyone listening to this
podcast is a one percenter and even if
you get a million people
audience
they'll be a one percenter and all their
all the people listening to you will
still be in that one percent because 98
of the [ __ ] country doesn't even know
what nato is if you ask them to define
it maybe now maybe after a week we could
get to like 30 percent right
right right
they could figure out they could figure
out an explanation that would result
exactly and like democrats want to do
all this complex nuanced like special
drill down policy [ __ ] i'm like dude
they don't [ __ ] know anything they
don't know the republican party has
collapsed into extremism they don't
understand that the entire republican
tribus the party conspired in a plot to
steal the election
in 2020 right and are all under federal
and [ __ ] investigation for they don't
know any of this [ __ ] okay right like
what i'm trying to get people to
understand is our messaging should do
two things it should motivate and and
disqualify the other party right but it
should it has to tell
our coalition
what is happening and what the stakes
are in the future for them
right right well and i think i think i
think we can manage to make that happen
but it is a big feat because there are
so many there's so many ears out there
to get this message into and not just
get it into but to get them to
understand in a way like you're saying
because this is this is kind of um i i
don't i don't bring out data here we
don't analyze you know a lot of stuff on
the show here we try to keep the
messaging very simple because i think i
think things are really simple like and
democrats want to use the phrase
universal pre-k and i'm like that's
ridiculous just say you want to start
school at age three instead of five like
that's so simple right there's things
that are so simple about when you're
talking about these things well we
universal healthcare what a dumb phrase
that is you just don't want to go broke
because of a medical bill like your
child yeah and donate i mean here it is
like so like i when when i when i hit
espn radio like i want to hit all the
sports radios right and what i'm going
to do with it is real [ __ ] simple
it's not complex at all i'm going to say
hey you don't do sports betting without
looking at stats why in the [ __ ] do you
vote that way right
right that's why that's the whole ad
except for the f-bomb right well because
the truth is those people who don't know
what nato is they know the exact
inflation rate that is supposed to be on
the football because tom brady tries to
play they're all capable of knowing it
right you know our culture
our civic culture is the re i mean at
the [ __ ] core of what's going on here
is this is this american public that
decade after decade has been cultured to
think politics is disgusting
and i'm morally superior by not
participating in it
right i mean that's what we teach people
have you ever met anyone and you ask
them this about politics or oh i don't
vote and then
there's right about like you're some
kind of insect because you [ __ ]
maintain your own government right right
but that's because
i'm blaming it on our culture right
right cultural socio
like culture
phenomena
in america and it tells people
you should have the right to have all
this privilege with no responsibility
and in fact don't even look over here
because it's icky
well and
so if we unwind that a bit because that
that is an interesting observation and i
like that observation that it is the civ
civic culture that we have to not
participate in things like politics but
to participate in things like uh sports
professional wrestling and it almost
seems like
that at the point when donald trump
entered the race as this clown and this
reality star that he was able to engage
some of those populations that that
didn't participate in that in that civic
culture and he created this own
different reality of civic culture like
they believe these things that aren't
even close to being true because somehow
that got engaged and
there's even more complicated things
where like in georgia in the runoff for
the senate runoff he was able to
convince a lot of his voters that hey
it's rigged anyways like like democrats
have done for years like oh it's i can't
you can't win a red it's a red state my
vote doesn't count so why should i vote
you know like even if i wanted to vote
you know those kind of cultures and
they'll have that mentality tony sitting
in one of the most competitive house
races in the [ __ ] country right
right right i mean like they won't even
know like they're like sitting in
georgia six but they're like oh not
georgia whatever idaho six and it's like
oklahoma or whatever it's it's it's the
red state but they're in a competitive
race and they should be voting you know
at the state legislative level and we
don't we don't do any of that education
they have i mean i just come back from
the church for the kirk show right like
that hasn't aired yet and maybe it will
never air but if it does like people are
going to see this turning point found
place that i went to tony i [ __ ] you not
it's sitting in one of the most
expensive lots in phoenix in tempe
arizona
and they have three different
large office structure buildings all
devoted to turning point and that
turning point usa by the way is charlie
kirk's organization which focuses on
converting college kids
and like his staffers in there they were
flying all around the us okay because
it's all financed by the tune of
billions of goddamn dollars and i can't
find one [ __ ] person to write a check
and let us shore up the democrats weak
sauce [ __ ] effort in 2020
right so so let's talk about that for a
second because um you did you did record
with charlie kirk right is that yeah
sure
and and yeah so they haven't given you
any any indication whether that is going
to release or not i i take it i take it
rachel uh bitcoffer ate charlie kirk's
lunch a bit i would maybe that's why
they won't release it you can
i don't know we'll see
right i mean i want it to be released so
that should tell you something right
[Laughter]
but what you're describing what you're
describing is uh one
this isn't the republican national
committee right this isn't the the party
this is a organization outside that uh
just one of them and you're saying that
they have floors and floors uh
they have uh
floors and floors in three structures
you can google map this [ __ ] turning
point usa headquarters in tempe phoenix
i'm sure you can [ __ ] see it dude
right and that is that is not the rnc
but they coordinate with the rnc it's
all centralized the messaging's all
centralized right and we don't have a
goddamn thing like that dude right
so so moving towards that i mean
do do you see the democrats creating
something like that because i i cuz cpac
cpac was last weekend right and and and
charlie
terry kirk's turning point usa has their
own cpac type thing right why don't
why don't democrats have a cpac title
you know to be clear there's no one in
charge of the democratic party there's
people in charge of various institutions
and they run bureaucracies okay they
don't run electoral strategy there is in
my opinion no brain trust for this party
but if there was and i was in charge of
it tony i can guarantee you the first
[ __ ] thing i'd be doing is
copying alec
the american legislative exchange
council which is the outfit that gives
them all their model ledge okay and then
i would turn our model ledge into wedge
[ __ ] and i would put that [ __ ] instead
legislatures and [ __ ] drive drive
drive enthusiasm the way they do
without
right um and the second thing i would do
is is judicial watch because that's a
conservative thing for the courts and
its main purpose over the years has been
to poison american public opinion
against the supreme court and to see it
no matter its mix as a liberal
you know um radical institution even
when even when it's not even close to
that and they're still talking about
that like they'll get one one
disfavorable decision and judicial watch
and all of these organizations pop and
so we need the courts we need a
federalist society too to go with that
so we have a robust law school program
that is encouraging kids to
to not fall into this trap with the
federalist society and then you know and
and of course the war room we need a war
room with a small cabinet a general with
autonomy and authority and we need to
start centralizing our [ __ ] right now or
we're going to lose that generic ballot
and enthusiasm fight and if we're losing
that
in september then i don't even need to
stick around for the election frankly do
you do you think if if the democrats can
manage to put together some
infrastructure and and i you know like
you said before i think the
infrastructure lives there it just
there's no connection between it right
there's no
it's all there it's just not there there
right so it's how you talk about it
right so like i i worked with one group
and they sent me a copy of something and
i love that they were using democrats
deliver right
everybody should be using that every
chance they get whenever they're talking
about any credit claiming topic but
anyway you know the first version was
deborah you know this was their first
revised version and it was democrats
deliver you know safe roads and bridges
and water and i'm like that's good
because now it's short and someone's
going to see it right that has to be
like a glance message to be able to see
because most people are only going to
read it they're going to take it out of
the box they're going to see it's
political junk mail and they're going to
throw it okay
and but i wrote back and i was like but
you can still be better and let me tell
you how
democrats deliver
roads that don't crush your spouse on
the way home from work right right water
that doesn't poison your children that's
it that's right you gotta make the image
right right give an image and i gotta
tell you you know i i'm trying to [ __ ]
myself out as much as possible to help
people with messaging to refine messages
to make them more valuable but it's not
going to replace a position where i can
actually force
a wall operation in these competitive
races right and those competitive races
at those 30 that you were saying earlier
because that's really where the rubber
meets the road because and we don't know
exactly what 30 right at this point
because some of those races haven't
developed but there's you know what
you're saying is 30 races there's maybe
30 seats at stake here that could that
could put us in a position where we
don't want to be where they're they're
talking because let's be frank if they
get those 30 seats they're not putting
kevin mccarthy as speaker of the house
that's not what's happening and even if
they do i mean is kevin gonna stand up
for democracy clearly not right right
right he manages to survive that right
the what will happen in the house is
catastrophic
and like in virginia when duncan took
over what he did
is catastrophic okay right within his
confines of he doesn't control the one
chamber that wasn't up for election that
cycle
thank god right right but he's got a
couple democrats who are gone full
apologetic democrat and they're joining
the republican coalition to overturn all
kinds of [ __ ] okay
and you have to
you have got to let the voters know this
is the change that you're signing up for
are you sure this is the kind of change
you want
right right why did you have to jump
today tony i'm so sorry i gotta no
that's okay that's okay i i appreciate
you joining us and we're having you here
like all day five days a week and i
can't wait to see how the show takes off
we got we got we've got big news next
week i
i know it's it's going to be big and i
think everyone's going to love it and i
hope to have you back next week and
we'll talk about that more rachel you
have a good day and uh make make sure
you send uh that um give us the link for
the the toolkit
yeah it's not up yet guys it's something
that me me and my my little uh padawan
are gonna be getting together now that
we've got a good amount of content to
get out there and then i'm going to
write up a little guide like
indivisible's guide for organizing
grassroots it will be rachel did coffers
guide to you know setting a referendum
narrative against the republican party
because no one else is gonna [ __ ] run
against the republicans guys if we don't
do it for the democrats so let's do it
let's get our message out there and
let's keep pounding rachel uh audience
stick around we'll be right back thanks
rachel have a good day see ya see you
soon
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop left you
customized from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking with us through the break
rachel bitkoffer there
hopefully we'll get that link out to her
tool kit so that way you guys can
be utilizing that toolkit not just
online but also in your messaging when
you're out there in the community
talking to people whether it's people at
your your community hall your your
church your school
that the person at the grocery store
because that's that's what's that's
what's gonna make this make this rubber
hit the road i had a friend um a couple
weeks ago remember remember the uh the
trump flushes document story trump eats
documents they were putting documents in
the burn bags i was talking to a friend
of mine and he's not he's not
totally disengaged in politics he votes
he's a voter
and we were talking about that story
about how
that the white house was putting uh
documents and burn bags to destroy
documents
and he's and i when i told him the story
he said what do you mean who wait what
what what huh you mean the people at
the capitol during the insurrection i'm
like no no no
no no no no no i'm talking about the
people in the white house i'm talking
about the trump administration
i'm talking about trump himself
the reports are that they were
destroying documents and he's like i've
never heard of this in my life
it's all over the news it's been all
over the news for the last two or three
days
never heard of it
never heard of it
and that's that's that's what rachel is
talking about
is because those things and what they
rely on is controlling the narrative
right they're controlling the outrage
what the outrage is
that's what the m ms and the bathroom
you know
the transgender bathroom thing and all
this stuff is they
yes they're bigots yes they're fascists
yes they're pieces of [ __ ]
but what they want people discussing
is the issues that they want them to
discuss
us
human beings who look at other people as
human beings generally aren't going to
walk around
discussing people who we don't know
their genitalia it's [ __ ] weird it's
a it's a disgusting bio weird thing to
do
to to discuss the morality of someone
else that we don't know their genitalia
it really is weird
or their identity it's really [ __ ]
weird it's really gross but they know
it's gross that's what they want and one
of the things that rachel said there at
the end which is super important about
the messaging like on a political
postcard that you would get right
it says democrats deliver clean water
because republicans want to poison your
children and it's not a lie
it's not a lie that's the [ __ ] truth
you go you go to michigan
to parts of michigan
where they poisoned they poisoned
children with lead in the water knew
they were doing it continue to do it
still to this day there's problems with
lead poisoning
they don't give a [ __ ]
they would they would poison your
children if they could if it meant that
they would gain power and keep power
what do they care they got power what do
they give a [ __ ]
you don't think they poison children
you don't think they would hide
poisoning children
i mean
think about it
but if you don't put it in that way if
you're just talking to someone
you say well yeah i vote democrat
because
democrats deliver on clean water and
clean air
oh well that's all warm and fuzzy
but the person who's sitting there that
you're talking to that doesn't generally
vote or doesn't generally know
about clean water and clean air
what are they going to give a [ __ ]
what do they care how's that going to
push them how's that going to motivate
them how's that going to engage them
that's what we need to be thinking about
and it's up to us because republicans do
this all the time you ever met one of
these [ __ ] you ever met one of
these [ __ ]
these these these
jesus guns babies people
all up in your grill in your face
and the reason why isn't because they're
so concerned about these issues
it's because of the outrage that is put
on to them
and projected onto them the strategic
outrage that is done
and they're using it as a weapon to turn
our country into a fascist state
so you have the option
you have the option
you can either ignore it and just
let it happen
or you can be in the fight you can be
engaged
because like rachel said you know
there's only one percent that you know
but maybe we are the one percent
politically engaged
with the stuff that we're engaged in
but we can turn it into three
and three turns into seven seven turns
into twenty one twenty one turns into
forty
then we got something right we get to
thirty forty percent of the country have
strategic outrage in the right [ __ ]
direction
for the things that they want
the republicans couldn't even muster the
[ __ ] courage
to clap for affordable insulin
they couldn't muster the courage
to clap
not to stand and give an ovation and
hoop and ha ha ha
they couldn't even
put their hands together
they couldn't even put their [ __ ]
hands together christina says those
people don't want to talk to me so
um christina i i get what you're saying
and and that that's what i was trying to
get at when i asked rachel who these
people are because these people aren't
generally they're not they're not trump
supporters they're not hillary
supporters they're not i mean they're
you know these these are people who are
completely politically and disengaged
they don't know who the secretary of
state is they don't know what nato is
they may know a little bit now because
they have to know because they have to
listen to someone at work talk about
this news
they have to look at people posting on
facebook about it
they don't generally know
the civics of our country they don't and
they're and they're disengaged not that
they don't want to or they can't or
they're not smart enough to
just they don't
for whatever reason whatever the reason
may be maybe they're more interested in
sports maybe they're really busy i mean
there's a lot of people out there that
have to work two or three jobs now
single moms that
um
it just it's it's not
it's not a it's a thing where
we have to find the people who are
disengaged
not republican democrat
it's that generic ballot that rachel's
talking about
people who don't have a party
affiliation they don't even know like if
you ask this person what's a democrat
what's a republican they wouldn't be
able to tell you they have no idea no
[ __ ] clue no clue they couldn't tell
you how our government works they
probably couldn't tell you the three
branches they probably couldn't tell you
much about the courts they probably
couldn't tell you but much about their
state government their local government
they don't know
they don't know but they could tell you
what they believe
they could tell you what they want from
civics
like they could tell you you you would
say
how
you like those pot holes in the road
they'd be like [ __ ] no i've had to buy
four sets of [ __ ] tires in the
last two years you could get them on a
tangent you get them on a political
tangent for hours and hours and hours
about a few [ __ ] potholes
right
you could get them on a tangent
you could talk about their schools like
well you know start up a conversation
you have conversations with people who
have children in the same school that
you are and these people again they're
they're not politically engaged they
don't have a
civic mind that maybe you guys do
because you're watching this stuff
you're paying attention and there's
nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that but the
problem is
is the messaging that they hear is the
messaging that they're going to act on
right so if they hear democrats bad and
they don't know anything else
right in between the years they just
hear democrats bad democrats bad
democrats bad democrats bad well that
must be the truth so i'll go vote
republican
but if you sat down and said
you know
how democrats bad how republicans bad
and you set that stuff aside
but you said what about the potholes
what about your your internet service
you like your internet service at your
house
what about this what about that
they they could start to understand why
it's so important to be civically
engaged
right
just like just like rachel said they
don't make sp these sports betting
people they don't make sports betting
decisions without looking at data
right without knowing the facts
without knowing who's out who's in who's
injured who's not
why wouldn't they do it for civics they
just they're not there yet and that's
okay that's what the generic ballot is
and that's what she's trying to say
christina said uh was talking about
conservatives
that babies guns jesus people yeah so i
don't i don't think those uh christine i
don't think those people are like
flippable right like we're we're not
gonna we're not gonna go and and like
and like uh um flip those people the the
jesus guns baby people that's not what
i'm saying what i'm saying what rachel's
saying is there's a generic ballot
there's there's a person out there that
is a political they're not affiliated
with not only that but affiliated with
the political party they don't
understand the political parties they
don't know who they are they don't they
don't really care to understand the
dichotomy between the two parties but
what they will understand
is what tyranny is
what autocracy could be like there's a
really glaring example right now in the
world
right now happening right before our
eyes
that is getting a lot of attention that
probably more than likely you could
convince someone and i'm not saying go
out there and have conversation after
conversation i'm just saying we we it is
up to us
is up to us to engage
with those folks
um whether it's your family your friends
people that you that go to school with
your children your church members your
community members people on facebook
that you know people on instagram people
on on social media in general
it is up to us to engage but we have to
do it correctly right
so many times i see i see someone
engaging with someone in the comment and
they're like oh well here's this article
here's that article here's this article
and that person's like i'm a fascist
well
who cares
you you can send fascist all kinds of
articles and it's not going to break
through
but someone who's a generic ballot
who only tweets about sports
that's all they tweet about the only
thing they tweet about they never tweet
about politics because they know nothing
about it
that's the person now the reason why
it's so difficult on social media is
because social media has all kinds of
different sides and we don't get to
engage on political twitter with sports
twitter generally because twitter's
algorithm doesn't allow for that but we
can do it in real life we can do it out
in the open um as you're talking to your
friends your family um and and keep that
messaging there keep the messaging there
uh in in every little inch every little
single thing that you may say to someone
even if you're checking out
in the grocery line you know
when you're talking about the high cost
of groceries because i know when you go
to the grocery store the groceries are
going up so when you're talking about
that have the messaging there why is it
why is it that it's doing that you know
because the person across from you
may be being told by someone they know
which total dismiss information
and being done a total disservice
and those people
are walking through life in an alternate
reality that isn't real because of
something that someone told them because
they're not engaged in politics and they
don't know
they're apolitical they don't know the
dichotomy
of our civics
so teach them
why you're standing there and the
greatest way to do that is when rachel
drops this
this tool chest this toolbox of
messaging you can have it but you can go
to the twitter or her twitter account
right now at rachel bitcoffer and you
can go through and you can look at that
messaging you can see how she talks
about issues
retweet her follow her read those tweets
i i know it sounds crazy but she gives
you she really does give you a road map
into how to talk to someone across from
you not just on twitter not just how you
tweet and how you word those tweets but
how you talk to someone that's
believable to you
right right right in front of your face
because we're gonna have more of that
this year
we're gonna have more of that as as the
coronavirus it you know has faded uh joe
biden reported that last night in the
state of the union
um
it really was funny to watch
people who were [ __ ] about mask oh we
have to wear masks not we're have to
wear mask anymore because the
numbers tell them they don't have to
i mean it's what democrats been saying
it's not a thing to control you are mind
control you silly bastards
it really is just when there's a virus
running around it's a good idea to have
something over your face so you don't
get sick it's just it's simple stuff
it's not [ __ ] complicated
but see there you go there again the
messaging they've been able to drive
that message
because it's scary message scary message
speaking of messaging
let's go to this that's on screen here
uh ron posted this video
from the freedom convoy trucker rally in
dc
oh boy it was a it was a doozy
i tweeted that one over like a wet fart
and a white thong
this is ridiculous really [ __ ]
ridiculous uh ford fisher i think is the
one who
uh made this video shows coming to me
let's uh let's let's turn this down i
don't know
but uh for you out there that aren't
watching
there is one guy on a very big stage
it's a very big stage it's a very big
open area i mean i would imagine that
you could have several hundred maybe
even
a thousand or two
in this little area around this stage
and it says
on the banner down below the stage it
says stage of freedom
like like i don't know william wallace
or some [ __ ] i don't know i i can't
figure it out
now if you look at this there's a a
couple people standing by the stage
there's one um lady here and i'm not
sure if these people are
just taking pity pictures of this person
or if it's like
i'm not really sure because there's one
woman here with her camera looks like
she's taking a video or picture
with a couple children in front of her
there's obviously a bunch of media
there's there's more media here
than there than there were anything
there's one person standing by the stage
with a flag here right you see him
holding the american flag but there's a
lot of cameras a lot of media
pretty much
just the guy on stage and media but
watch this a place that i used to raise
my children and provide for my family i
had these government officials coming to
me oh wait a second wait a second now i
know i haven't confirmed this
but maybe just maybe you know he when he
was saying that he was kind of pointing
over here towards these
this uh where the children and the
ladies standing maybe just maybe this i
you know i don't know i'd have to get
someone to verify this but maybe that is
his family that has come to watch him
and record him which you know i i don't
begrudge him that
um you know he rented this big stage to
have this big show and
unfortunately it went over like a wet
fart and a white thong but they would
record him doing this let's let's finish
to my face saying you may not be open
huge red flag from the start
didn't it make sense started reading the
bible more starting the constitution
more something's off i i'm not sure who
this guy is is this guy with the [ __ ]
gym that he you know he
and this is supposed to be like the
freedom rally thing the freedom convoys
they're calling it
you see ron says wow this huge freedom
convoy trucker rally in dc is lit
really making a bold statement three
weeks of hype from steve bannon every
day and that's the most important thing
and i think ron's on to something here
steve bannon was pumping this thing
every [ __ ] day
i mean oh it's going to be the biggest
thing ever they're going to shut down
the economy it's going to destroy joe
biden it's going to be the end of joe
biden blah blah blah blah blah blah
just nonsense after nonsense nonsense
and really honestly um if you look at
truckers in the trucking industry in
this country there's no way that they
were gonna put together a freedom convoy
not even [ __ ] close that was gonna
shut down the economy get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] if you go back to
2020 in uh march april may june if you
remember that the people that were
keeping our economy alive and the people
who were working some of the longest
hours were the were the [ __ ] the
essential workers and truckers were the
essential workers
they were without the trucks you
wouldn't
trump's toilet paper fiasco would have
evolved into the a total collapse of
civil society
we didn't have [ __ ] toilet paper you
remember that
you know they want to talk about [ __ ]
empty shelves biting
well [ __ ]
it it took it took months for people to
feel secure about how they were going to
wipe their ass
i mean that that's how bad it
the supply chain was
as he would say supply change
you ever heard him say it hey i'm
talking about the cheeto dust mobster
trump he says supply change he doesn't
even know what he didn't know the words
[ __ ] idiot but ron makes a good point
here that this was supposed to be huge
and it's and
christina christina says uh freedom
truck singular rally right it's just a
truck rally just one just one truck just
one
ew
ann says all toilets should have bidets
uh and you know the people who had
bidets they weren't worried about toilet
paper you make a very good point there
you make a very good point
and you bidet elitist
[Laughter]
i've never i've never i've never used
one so
i can't i can't say
one way or the other rather i would
prefer a bidet or i would prefer the old
the old
toilet paper you know the the
old-fashioned way i don't know i'm just
saying all i'm saying though is that
without the truckers in 2020 being
essential workers and them doing their
jobs because they got paid to do their
jobs it's called capitalism it really is
pretty [ __ ] simple to understand a
little bit
but without without that without that
there would have been a drop in civic
society because
no one would have known how or when or
why they were gonna wipe their ass
and that's pretty sad but that's the
truth
that's the truth okay let's um
uh i wanna show a few other things and
then i want to go to
uh okay here here is here speaking of uh
marjory taylor green which we're going
to get to the marjorie taylor green
lauren bober thing i promise i'm going
to tear them apart we are 17 minutes
into the second hour holy moly we've
moved along quickly this is uh you guys
remember at cpac marjorie taylor greene
went to a white nationalist rally uh and
cheered on a bunch of nazis act like
after the fact she's like oh no i had no
idea they were nazis
i had no idea they were nazis nick
fuentes is a nazi are you kidding me
had no idea no clue but kevin mccarthy
here has asked about this situation
about her attending the white nationals
rally cheering them on and speaking to
them
let's listen can you please respond to
marjorie taylor green attending the
white nationalist uh conference over the
weekend
you know what um
i commented on that on yesterday
i i understand your job i understand
what you're trying to do
i've already commented on that we've got
a war in europe that we have not had
since world war ii
we've got we've got people in the
village i love
i love how this [ __ ] thinks he
can pull the wool over our eyes don't
you
this [ __ ] [ __ ] box here
he thinks he can distract us with a war
that he supported putin on
what get the [ __ ] out of here you had to
put your cheeto dust knee pads on you
can't condemn trump
for talking about how great a real
estate deal is that putin had for two
dollars worth of sanction he he's gonna
take ukraine
only two dollars worth of sanctions
which you know we were were beginning to
see that the sanctions
are much more than two dollars maybe
that's why donald trump was terrified of
the sanctions
i i would imagine
i would imagine the flow of money to
oligarchs and his laundering washing
machine
has dried up
but here kevin mccarthy can't condemn
trump talks about war can't can't
[ __ ] muster up enough courage to say
marjorie taylor green did the wrong
thing
and we don't we condemn white
nationalism in our party and we will not
we will not tolerate our members of our
party in my caucus
attending white nationalist rallies and
cheering on a bunch of [ __ ] nazis
can't even handle it you can't even do
it kev you can't even do it just [ __ ]
quit buddy it's over you're a [ __ ]
weak piece of [ __ ]
rather you whether you are in the
republican party or not you're a weak
piece of [ __ ] you'll never be a leader
you'll never be you'll never amount to
any kind of thing that resembles a
[ __ ] leader just quit man it's enough
it's enough of the [ __ ]
now i tweeted how big is the bag of
horse dicks that you want kevin mccarthy
to eat that's what i tweeted about this
like that's my thought process like this
[ __ ] [ __ ] box
like i would love to watch him sit and
have to eat french fried horse dicks for
about 20 days
just a big pile of them and i i wouldn't
get them fresh for i mean they'd be
fresh in the beginning
you know just
they would keep getting older and older
you know it's a big pile of horse sticks
and my big bag right a huge bag
but this [ __ ] right here he needs to he
needs to hang it up it's enough of this
[ __ ] you're not being the leader that
you need to be not just to america but
to your party in general
you're leading down your your party down
a path
that is you can't turn around you can't
get out of the cul-de-sac you're
painting yourself into a white
nationalist corner here
not only not only were you [ __ ]
backing putin before
putin was cool before he wasn't cool
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] continued to placate to
putin and his murderous dictorial ways
and you can't even condemn the
[ __ ] who is his puppet
who is his puppet
who while he was the president of the
united states was trying to give ukraine
to putin why would putin why the [ __ ]
would putin invade ukraine while donald
trump was president when donald trump
was trying to make sure that he handed
ukraine to putin on a platter without
going to war why the [ __ ] would putin do
that
rather donald trump was president now or
then there's no way putin would have
invaded ukraine because donald trump as
the president united states was doing
all his bidding for him
with ukraine jesus christ he all but
[ __ ] said it on the stage he all but
did it when he tried to pressure
zielinski
into into making sure that he could he
could have something to beat joe biden
because he knew he was going to get his
[ __ ] ass stomped by joe biden
trump
trump knew he was going to get his
[ __ ] ass kicked by joe biden
that's why he was terrified that's why
he wanted president zielinski to have an
investigation oh look here look at this
thing here
ukraine's investigating him and hunter
biden
and hunter biden's laptop
and emails the email lady somehow
somehow she works in there too
so that he could be joe biden because he
knew he was going to get his ass kicked
and they placated to that too
oh he wasn't he wasn't withholding
weapons he wasn't withholding aid and by
the way even if he was withholding aid
it's within his control and power and
the reason why he would do that is
because ukraine is corrupt
and and and because ukraine is corrupt
putin definitely definitely could take
it with or without the weapons
and they voted not to impeach him and
remove him even after a quid pro quill
high crimes and misdemeanors
and then they did it twice after he
tried to overthrow the constitution
united states
so yeah yeah kev you have to answer the
[ __ ] question about white
nationalists because you are where you
are because you placate the white
nationalists
because you are a [ __ ] white
nationalist i don't give a [ __ ] if kevin
mccarthy believes in white nationalism
or not
when you continue to go to dinner
and sit at the dinner table with a bunch
of [ __ ] nazis
and have dinner and
cheer them on and back slap with a bunch
of [ __ ] nazis you're a nazi
don't give a [ __ ] kev
so hang it up buddy either that or eat a
big bag of horse dicks you piece of [ __ ]
all right let's give credit for that
video
okay
let's see what else we got here
[Music]
i think i think we'll go back to the um
the bobo marjorie taylor green let's go
to the tweety treats and the trendy
trends let's see if they're still
trending
um today's ash wednesday
for all of you out there uh
accounting uh pal is trending breaking
ukraine war impact on u.s economy highly
uncertain
central bank will need to be nimble in
responding
uh the
pal says the fed chair pal says
which is probably a case where
the you know gas prices have gone up
because of the oil you heard last night
that the president united states is
working not with just our oral reserves
but all reserves around the world to
relieve the pressure um that will happen
as as the sanctions on russia
and some of those pipelines are shut
down and the world's gonna have to stand
together it does it does mean it is
going to affect our pocketbooks here a
bit in this country even at a time where
we shouldn't affect our pocket books it
is that's why democrats and uh should
push
for the inflation more inflation relief
in the form of the child tax credit and
really tax credits in general
i don't think i don't i think those tax
credits should actually be extended to
to all americans not just american
families with children
retired americans americans on social
security um it should be that inflation
protection through those tax credits
that go into your bank account each
month at least for the next 12 or 18
months um i'm not sure how long this
conflict is going to go on but it's
going to cause more inflation in parts
of the economy especially in the fuel
sector
as we eat up part of our reserves and
the world eats up part of their reserves
now
the other the other thing about the
inflation protection that needs to
that needs to really
happen here is to crack down on the
gouging
joe biden talked about it last night
not only in the form of snuffing out all
these companies who stole our money
in the coronavirus packages where they
took coronavirus money but also
also people who are price gouging
that definitely needs to be uh something
that happens and not just inside the
department of justice we need to pass
legislation that needs to be first and
foremost and get that in into on the
president's desk so that american people
are protected from price gouging whether
it be drugs or anything else whatever it
is
he talked about last night he pointed
out that meat packing there's four
[ __ ] companies you got four choices
in the meat business so if you're a
farmer out there you only got four
[ __ ] choices that's not competition
that's not competition we need to have
more competition in these markets um
that's what that's what that's what
supply side supply side republicans
would want
so get on it
get on it
and that's some of the messaging that we
can convey
now it is super important uh for this
not for the inflation protection not to
just happen into the bank accounts of
americans
through the child tax credits or through
tax credits in general but also
also where we're breaking up this
[ __ ] gouging that is happening to the
american the american people
uh with these record amount of profits
okay let's go down to
number 14. lauren bobert is still
trending
beau bert is still trending
the washington post here reports lauren
bobert a critic of biden's immigration
policies chanted to build a wall as the
president spoke of the southern border
the chant was drowned that by bipartisan
applause for biden's comments on
immigration he couldn't [ __ ] hear
now now to be fair to to to dip [ __ ]
here to lauren beauberg that room is not
miked well right like the room isn't
miked for to catch
the chance and the and the back talk and
and the [ __ ] from the crowd right
it's really not it's really not miked
and designed that way this is c-span so
they don't have it miked up that way
right like in a lot of halls and stuff
when they're making a recording of like
you know like a like a a stand-up
routine like when you watch stand-up
comedy on netflix that room is miked to
catch the actual sound that's in the
room it's not what happens on c-span
that's not what happens
so what happens so she got drowned out
here
and of course washington post has this
this tweet here
so i'll retweet that and give credit to
washington post thank you washington
post
um for your little insight there let's
go to let's do this let's go to video
you guys know i love video let's go to
the video section of this
um so uh here's uh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so here's here's
uh as speaking of p other pieces of [ __ ]
here's marjory taylor green you know
they're not vindictive at all they're
not pieces of [ __ ] at all this is the
cabinet of the president united states
walking into the chamber watch what she
does
visually turns her back they turn their
back on the cabinet
um
you know
again again the
[Laughter]
they don't want to seem petty
you know uh marjorie taylor green was
the one that went on alex jones infowar
like last week and said they think i'm
crazy it pisses me off that they think
i'm great you are [ __ ] crazy
you are crazy okay here's bobert and
green chanting build a wall apparently
murder advanced liberty and justice
come on okay let's see
let's get this up
advanced liberty and justice
we need to secure our border and fix the
immigration system
[Applause]
okay so you see it's hard to hear here
but at this point in the tape
here is joe biden says this about
immigration form
and here's the thing
he says it in a way
he says it in a way to secure our
borders and to do something about
immigration reform like he says it in a
way that's not like we we need to let
all
all people in our country no matter what
like that's not what he said somebody
said it all he said we need to secure
our border and we need to work on
immigration reform
now i don't know if it's a trigger for
marjorie taylor greene and lauren bobert
when they are
talking about immigration to immediately
chant build a wall because they think oh
we're at a trump rally we're at a nazi
rally build a wall build a wall here's
the thing
here's what it actually is do you want
to know what it really is do you want to
know what happened in that moment
do you want to know
joe biden is talking about reasonable
border security security and actually
immigration reform that we've needed for
decades
that's what he's talking about
it would fix a lot of problems that we
have like if we actually worked on the
problems that we have as opposed to
ignoring them
when we chant things like build a wall
because
when lauren beaubert and marjorie taylor
greene are chanting build a wall
they don't mean border security
they don't mean they they don't want
immigration
they what they're chanting this is what
they're chanting are you ready for this
it's really not hard
we hate brown people we hate brown
people we hate brown people we hate
brown people we hate brown people you
got it
when they're chanting build a wall
that's code
just like when they chant let's go
brandon
let's go brandon means [ __ ] joe biden
they can't say they can't say out loud
[ __ ] joe biden they can't say enchant
the word [ __ ]
so they have to change it to let's go
brandon
let's go brandon
let's go brandon
to be all warm and fuzzy inside that way
they can say it in church they can chant
it in public hell they can chant it on
the floor the on the floor of the house
while joe biden's giving the state of
the union
when they chant
build a wall
in this moment
they're not talking about building a
wall because if they really were [ __ ]
talking about building a wall if that's
what the [ __ ] they were talking about
they would have done held the last
leader who promised them a wall
accountable for it
you think they would still be [ __ ]
trump sycophants
if it was about an actual physical wall
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
it never had anything to do with the
physical wall that was all facade that
was all [ __ ] just like the let's go
brandon shirts and the let's go brandon
nazi flags
it's code
and they know what the code is
they all know what the code is
they know it
it's got nothing to do with the physical
wall on a border border security or
immigration reform at all
what marjorie taylor green and lauren
bobert were doing last night
when the president united states was
trying to
trying to help
the republican party
come to their side
to make sure
that he could sell a message that he's
willing to work on immigration reform
and border security
he did the same thing with the the
defund the police and fund the police
they chant to build a wall not because
they want a physical wall
it's because they hate brown people
and that's what they're saying
we hate brown people we hate brown
people we hate brown people
we hate brown people just like when they
can't lock her up
they don't actually mean
lock hillary clinton up they don't
actually mean that that's not what they
mean
that's not what they mean if they really
meant that and they were really serious
about it they would be completely and
utterly [ __ ] pissed at donald trump
they would see him as a failure and
there's no way they would give him any
[ __ ] money any [ __ ] time for any
griff that he had
no [ __ ] way wouldn't buy a manga hat
wouldn't buy a manga shirt wouldn't buy
a trump flag wouldn't have a trump
bumper sticker on any kind of [ __ ]
vehicle that they owned that guzzled
gallons of gallons of gas that they
could [ __ ] about how how high the costs
are
not one
because when they say when they say lock
her up
they mean we hate women we hate women we
hate women we hate brown people [ __ ] joe
biden we hate that's what they mean
that's what they mean that's the code
talk
and that's what they're doing here
so this bill the wall [ __ ] this this
them lashing out
the hilarious part about it is
they were the only two saying it
and it really is rich that they couldn't
even get the white [ __ ] fascist males
the white shrinkly old ball sacks to
participate
in the chant
they couldn't
couldn't get their own party who was
supposed to be sick of fans to trump
it's pathetic it really is [ __ ]
pathetic and i'm kind of glad they did
it
because you know why if they wouldn't
have done it
we wouldn't get to say that all those
people who didn't chant it they feel the
same way
they feel the same way they wanted a
chant we hate brown people they wanted
to chant we hate brown people they would
love the chant we hate brown people like
on the daily
kevin mccarthy would love to come to the
microphone and denigrate brown people
would love it would love to give
bellatio to vladimir putin in front of a
microphone because donald trump does it
why not he's the leader of their party
okay let's let's move on here
to some more bobert green
thanks for the uh the video here i'm
going to give credit for the video
[Music]
okay more video
here's the huffington post
uh posted a video let's see what this
this is the uh this is when joe biden
this is even more [ __ ] bile by the
way this is even this is way more vile
than anything that was chanted about
about building a wall and they hate
brown people this is way more vile
joe biden is talking about his son here
beau biden
who is a who is a veteran
and who passed away from brain cancer
he's talking about burn pits in
afghanistan and iraq
and right of those burn pits are causing
men like his son and women and soldiers
like his son
to have
brain cancer and certain types of cancer
from the fumes from those toxic pits
now whether it be headaches death
uh the the
soldiers that were near and in those
pits
deserve our attention
they were serving us as a country and us
as a country should serve them just like
just like 911 the 911 first responders
they were serving their country and we
should serve them but let's listen to
the [ __ ] gross vile [ __ ]
and lauren beaubert said
[Music]
okay lauren bobert boudin heckled biden
is what the headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
so
when joe biden says
a cancer that would put them in
flag-draped coffins i know
he's talking about his son
everyone in the room knows he's talking
about his son everyone who knows joe
biden or anything about joe biden
for half a [ __ ] second knows what the
[ __ ] he's talking about here
knows that the reason why one of the
reasons why he gave that he didn't run
in 2016 in the primary against hillary
clinton is because his son beau biden
has just died from brain cancer
now it is unproven i think and he even
mentions it in the speech rather those
toxic fumes that he lived near
near those burn pits had anything to do
with his cancer or not
but joe biden is committed to to
american soldiers that if
if there's even a chance even a chance
that he's committed
to making sure that those people receive
treatment and receive the compensation
rather in health care that our aid that
they need um because they serve their
country but here lauren bobert here
lauren bobert
yells out
as as joe biden is speaking of his son
who served our country honorably
as a veteran
and as a and as a public servant
honorably
yells and screams about 13 dead soldiers
in afghanistan as we were leaving who
did their duty
those honorable 13 who did their duty
just as beau biden did
that vile piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
someone who has given service to no one
other than herself
who serves no one other than her in her
[ __ ] social media accounts
to say to say what she says here you can
even see lindsey graham
cringe watch
even lindsey graham
that piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
understands what the [ __ ] happened
look at him
he knows what just happened
is going to be damaging not to joe biden
not to joe biden
not to the country because i believe the
country would would honor beau biden and
what beau biden the service that beau
biden gave
regardless of party affiliation and if
you wouldn't you're a [ __ ] puke
one of those
and he says
watch lindsey graham
watch
[ __ ]
or shut up i don't know which one it is
shut up
[ __ ]
shut up one of those it's one of those
it's one of those
and immediately after lindsey graham
realizes what had happened
joe biden continues about his son beau
biden
one of those
one of those soldiers was my son major
beau biden
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
that he lived near that his hooch was
near
in iraq and earlier than that in kosovo
is the cause of his brain cancer the
disease of so many other troops
so when you have
when you have a president united states
that has empathy
mj wants me to play it again i will play
it again
we'll play it from the beginning here
listen headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
one of those
one of those soldiers was my son major
beau biden
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
that he lived near that his hooch was
near
in iraq and earlier than that in kosovo
is the cause of his brain cancer the
disease of so many other troops
now you want to know what who
republicans are do you want to know who
republicans are do you want to know who
they are they're lauren bobert they're
marjorie taylor green you don't believe
me
that's who they are
we had we had thomas massey
andrew clyde and chip roy this week
vote in favor of lynching
we have lauren bobert heckling the
president united states as he talks
about his son dying from cancer
the president united states
delivers republicans an avenue to
immigration reform and border security
on a platter
the democrat the liberal democrats out
there you liberals out there
you aoc liberals out there would [ __ ]
despise joe biden for signing a bill
that he would sign with republicans
on immigration reform and border
security
you would despise it
but he would do it he's giving them an
avenue
all the while them chanting build a wall
which they mean we hate brown people
it's real
they are lauren bobert
the republican party
is lauren bobert
uh let's see if we can find
it it's the same video over and over
um
of her just
being completely vile
uh mj says i think he said oh [ __ ]
i i almost think that he says oh [ __ ]
too
um i i think i think lindsey graham says
oh [ __ ] because he knows he's worried
about what she said and how to affect
gabe here has a video since lauren
bobert is trending
um this is a um
an actual video
and i'm gonna get in trouble for playing
the song but we're gonna play it anyways
[ __ ] it
this [ __ ] trunt
[Music]
okay lauren
that's part of the video so you put up
here i gave people diarrhea
a lot of people don't know the um the
the significance of the i gave people
diarrhea if you know the story of lauren
bober you know that they had a um
a uh like like a street festival you
ever been to a street festival and her
restaurant had like a little tent at a
street festival where they were serving
loose meat sandwiches
and those loose meat sandwiches
made people [ __ ] have diarrhea
like a [ __ ] like they were sick
i think they even i think they even got
a knock on their uh their health code
license or whatever it is their food
license from the health department maybe
got shut down for a few days or
suspended because they weren't handling
the food properly
who could imagine who could imagine that
lauren bobert is so [ __ ] stupid that
her people around her couldn't even
handle loose meat sandwiches properly to
make sure people didn't get sick this is
the person that you want in charge of
the wall this is the person you want in
charge of immigration reform this is the
person that you want to go to congress
for
you can't even handle to make sure that
people don't get sick from loose meat
sandwiches get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
okay let's see what other video that we
have of lauren boo boo
the the boo-boo and it's the bobo the
clown
um actually you know if you go to gabe's
um
uh
merch store he has a bobo the clown
t-shirt it's a really nice one um just
go to you can go to uh his twitter page
i am gabe sanchez and click on his link
or you can go to thetonymichaels.com
and you can uh i've got his merch store
on there now you can go get you a
lauren uh bobo the clown bobo the clown
t-shirt they're over there i wish i had
a picture of him i'd show you a picture
but um go over there actually you know
what here here's what we'll do i'll show
you here
we'll get the uh
let me pull it up here let me let me
just pull it up here see if we can find
the bobo the clown t-shirt
now it's a good t-shirt i always like
that here it is okay let's see here yep
okay
are you ready
here it is
here it is for everyone to see here's
the bobo the clown t-shirt bobo the
clown
it's on his merch store
again just go to i am gabe sanchez on
twitter uh follow him there while you're
there go to his store and get you a bow
with a clown t-shirt or you can go to
the tonymichaels.com
um gabe sanchez's merch store is there
so go get you a bobo the clown t-shirt
maybe maybe maybe get them as as gifts
[Laughter]
okay let's go back to the trendy trends
and the tweety tweets here uh see what
else uh what what else did we have today
on the docket we had uh oh nancy pelosi
mcfaul beau biden uh dean fund the
police pal and trump putin
yeah let's let's see oh 78 of americans
uh here's another [ __ ] [ __ ] poll
here's another [ __ ] poll
that's gonna pump right-wing propaganda
you see how they do this
you see
uh brooklyn dad to find here has a cbs
news poll shows that 78 of americans who
watched the state of the union approve a
president biden speech last night that's
more like it well you know maybe maybe i
was maybe i jumped the gun on the
on the pole oh maybe i jumped the gun
maybe i jumped the gun do you believe
this pole do you actually believe that
78 percent of people liked his
speech do you think that's true i mean i
like this speech i like what he said i
actually think if you look at his speech
as a whole and you gave it to a
republican to give that speech i think a
republican could have gave that speech
now a lot of people that might piss him
off i might piss some liberals off that
might piss left-leaning people off
but you know there it goes avenger
resister says 78 of americans approve of
joe biden's speech because they trust
him the other 22 are still waiting for
trump's health care plan
next week it'll be next week next week
and while he's down at mar-a-lago
golfing he'll he'll work that up for you
he'll work it up for you
he'll work it up for you okay let's see
here
i i
um robin says yes
i think robin you're saying that 78 of
americans
uh looked at joe biden's speech and
liked joe biden speech i i would say
that 78 of people maybe who watched it
right and that's what me and rachel were
talking about earlier
you think you think all of america
watched you think all of america watched
the state of the union last night ah
[ __ ] no
[ __ ] no
robin says yes so that's what she's
talking about so it is very possible
that uh in the high 70s
of people who actually watched the
speech and listen to what he said i
believe 78 of the people who watched it
who listen to it could probably say yes
they like the speech they trust joe
biden
they like what what he said
they think he's going to do a good job
for what the state of the union is
that's probably about right but the
problem is
that people didn't watch
people don't watch
they don't participate in civil activity
that's what me and rachel are trying to
tell you
is that there's people out there that if
you ask them what the state of the union
was they wouldn't even know what that
means
they they wouldn't even know when you
were kids and there was three channels
on tv right there was [ __ ] three
channels sometimes two
sometimes two but mostly three abc nbc
cbs sometimes like pbs depending on
where you're at right public
broadcasting
but those three network stations right
long ago long before cable long before
satellite
when the president of the united states
came on tv
that's the only thing that was on
[ __ ] tv
you couldn't turn on your cell phone you
couldn't play wordle
you couldn't look at facebook you
couldn't browse twitter you couldn't
turn it to netflix and watch your
favorite documentary you couldn't watch
your favorite stand-up special you
couldn't watch the the ninth season of
seinfeld you couldn't turn it to hulu
and get caught up on
on episodes of your favorite sitcoms
you couldn't do that
if you wanted to watch tv that night in
the present united states was on tv well
you're [ __ ] you're going to watch the
present united states it doesn't matter
if it's joe biden donald trump barack
obama george bush of course in this day
and age
we have those the ability to do
something different
now a lot of people would turn off the
tv
but they actually watched they had to
participate they had to engage to some
level they had to listen to what the
president was saying
that's the whole reason for the march
down down the goddamn hall down the the
aisle with the cabinet in the supreme
court so you can see who those people
are
so you know who those people are
we don't today
people aren't watching the state of the
union
they're not watching
how in the hell could we keep people's
attention for more than five seconds
when they're scrolling down a [ __ ]
social media feed
and that is what rachel is saying
if you remember what she's saying is
that quick glance that one phrase where
do you point where do you aim
how do you get people engaged how do you
get them to understand the messaging
that you have in an instant and it's in
less than a half a second
how why where
and for what
democracy pro-democracy
okay let's go back uh the 78 of
americans apparently
that listened to the speech 78 of those
people loved
those
loved the speech love the speech of
course you did of course
of course okay
let's see what is there anything else
that has come up on the on the trendy
trends u.n general assembly votes to
condemn russia over invasion of well no
[ __ ]
looks like there's some news here
uh let's see brian's got brian's got to
hears
brian tyler cohen says breaking the un
general assembly assembly adopts
resolution condemning russia's invasion
of ukraine
141 to five is the vote
five oh and 35 nations abstaining that's
[ __ ] gross
that's gross that really is gross the no
verts were belarus which they're neutral
because right now they're they have
article four uh a retread uh north korea
syria and of course syria and russia
uh of course north korea syria and
russia
this is the bedfellows
this is who donald trump is supporting
listen
this is this is you talking about
messaging here it is
right here
right here anyone who has a maga hat on
who has a trump flag on who has a trump
sticker on their car
who says trump 2024 trump this or trump
that or whatever build a wall lock her
up all that [ __ ] all that code talk
let's go brandon nazis all those [ __ ]
nazis
they are on the side of north korea
syria and russia
got it they are on the side of north
korea syria and russia those dictorial
murderous regimes
there is your messaging
oh you're for trump then you're for
north korea syria and russia you're for
murderous dictators you're you're for a
oppressed oppressing totalitarianism
that wants to murder their own citizens
that's what you're for if you're wearing
a manga hat if you're wearing manga hat
you support trump you are you might as
well be for kim jong-un and assad you
love them
you want you want a kim jong-un to rule
us you want an assad to rule us
hell you want thomas massey andrew clyde
and chip roy you want them to be for
lynching you're for lynching the
republican party is for lynching the
republican parties they hate brown
people they said it last night they
stare their spokes people their
spokeswomen marjorie taylor green and
lauren bobert said when joe biden said
he wants the border secure and
immigration reform they said we hate
brown people
they said it out loud they were chanting
it we hate brown people we hate brown
people we hate brown people they were
chanting it
lauren bobert
denigrated
a dead soldier
an honorable veteran
[ __ ] all over
an honorable veteran
while joe biden was speaking about that
honorable veteran who's given his
service not only to the military but
civil service she's [ __ ] all over him
she's anti-american military
she's anti-soldier
and they're pro-north korea they're
pro-syria they're pro-russia and they're
pro-murderous dictators and they love
fascism they love it they're [ __ ]
nazis
don't lose that messaging
when someone tells you
when someone tells you
oh well
republicans this we're but nope nope
nope nope they're not republicans
anymore
they they love north korea they love
syria they love russia
they love trump you love trump right oh
i love trump trump 2024 then you're for
murderous dictators you want trump to be
assad you want trump to be kim jong-un
that is what they want that is what he
wants that is what his followers want
that is what you are
you are a nazi you are a fascist you
want totalitarianism you want trump to
murder everyone but you until he gets to
you then you don't want him to murder
you that's how it works that's how
totalitarianism works that has
authoritarianism works
just hide watch what happens with putin
they are on the side
of ken jong-un
assad and putin
and you don't believe me you just see
what go go look at the statements that
donald trump has made about kim jong-un
go look at him the [ __ ] love letters
hell he tried to steal the love letters
from us
that he wrote that wrote to trump
loves it
loves it
okay so uh having this news that the u.n
general assembly
um has voted
overwhelmingly uh with ukraine here
uh to condemning russia in the invasion
of ukraine here is uh looks like here's
some video of it
the recount has here let's play the
result of the vote is
as follows
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the result
the result of
you're not going to silence the crowd
they're standing with ukraine they're
standing with democracy
they're not just clapping for ukraine
they're clapping for pro-democracy
for liberty for freedom
against totalitarianism that is
authoritarian murder is as follows
in favor 41
against 5
abstentions
35
draft resolution a slash
es-11 slash l1 is adopted
so
as as they stand with trump as they
stand with him with their maga hats and
their trump flags their trump 2024
bumper stickers
the thomas massey's the andrew clyde's
the chip roy's the jd vance's the steve
bannon's
the paul goes ours their mo brooks
the kevin mccarthy's the mitch
mcconnells the lauren boberts
the marjorie taylor greens of our
country
the fascists the nazis the white
supremacists
who pile around with nick fuentes
and go to nazi rallies talk about
totalitarianism
fawn over putin like tucker carlson
sean hannity and fox news
just know
just know what the messaging is
and pump that message
democrats will deliver you democracy
republicans want to destroy it
at all means necessary
come back tomorrow we'll have the
interview for you tomorrow of the ottawa
truckers data dump
the gibson go data dump we will do that
tomorrow
noon eastern 11 central always same time
same place youtube twitter twitch
every single weekday every single
weekday here and we've got big news
coming next week hopefully we'll
announce that on friday
we will talk to you soon see you
tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules no boundaries i think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking